yeah if you are aware of that old
mythology you would love to play as neo
matrix jumong tricks I think that that
is not the real world John wick for and
matrix for are gonna come out on the
same day
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars this is
rogue theory and today we are theorizing
about the matrix for its coming May 2021
mr. breathtaking kion who's coming back
exam it's a major nerd event that for me
is right up there with Marvel phase four
and who knows maybe Marvel phase four
who could be like revealed as another
matrix simulation all of this is a
simulation but no this is not a glitch
in the matrix I am Eric boss but I'm
just subbing in for Phillip this week so
that you know he can go unplug himself
whatever he's doing we wish him well but
he'll be back next week but since I am
in charge this week maybe this related
me winning the golden rogue elast
will see the golden rogue it was the red
pill I'm gonna make you guys pitch me
theories about the movie that I made
creepy crappy short films about a middle
school The Matrix universe are we
excited free their minds with me are
some of my favorite lines of code marina
master episode we're gonna theorize
about future seasons of HBO's The
Watchmen because it's not canceled
forever it's kind of comeback right yeah
we're gonna figure it out but first
we're gonna get into this new Matrix
movie and it's coming very soon guys
it's shooting is gonna start in a few
weeks
Chicago the script is rumored to be
amazing Keanu and carrie-anne moss are
coming back lana wachowski is back Jada
pinkett-smith is coming back the guy
played the Merovingian which I know you
all care very passionately is back yaya
Abdul Mateen of course dr. Manhattan
Black Manta he's going to star as lead
character aside Jessica hen wick who is
Colleen Ling from iron fist now there
were some reports that Yaya was cast as
a young Morpheus but those haven't been
a hundred percent confirmed yet Neil
Patrick Harris and Jonathan Groff are
gonna be playing supporting roles it
sounds like they're gonna be pulling a
similar move that the force awakens did
with Star Wars right you're gonna take
some of the old stars from the old
generation bring them back in some new
way to pass the torch to the new leads
for hopefully a new trilogy
I know Warner's hoping for that but if
you remember Matrix Revolutions it ended
with neo and Trinity both dead yeah so I
want you guys to pitch me your
Rochus theories I do think that the end
of Matrix Revolutions is a bit of a
misdirect I think that that is not the
real world I think that is another
sequence in the matrix that the the
machines the robots programmed to
confuse humility whoa so they created
this kind of basically Jesus Christ
sacrifice for neo and and Trinity in her
own way sacrificing herself to make the
humans believe that they've accomplished
something that like that they've been
saved by these figures yes and to not
ask any more questions and that's where
we find ourselves in the year 2020 world
similar to our world now a lot of people
are living in big cities and out in
farms and and there's Technology and
everyone has a job and a purpose and
they're constantly surrounded by imagery
literature advertising the same way that
you know government and religions and
this isn't a knock on any of those but
will advertise to us now you know where
with its constant recruitment right yeah
it's like you know be saved follow this
or whatever and they're and they're
reminding us of the great sacrifices neo
and Trinity made for us so that we don't
ask any more questions I love it you
know we don't seek out any new wisdom
because that would be disrespectful to
the people who have given so much yeah
kind of allegorical to what goes on
today you know I mean there are a lot of
things that we're told not to question
any further because it's disrespectful
to the people that came before us so I
believe we see our new characters kind
of getting their own version of red
pills I think the idea of updating it up
you know updating our technology becomes
so so so important so I'd like to think
of this as like there's going to be an
update to the matrix man that's going to
cause as it often does with our
technology issues glitches mistakes in
the matrix and that's going to awaken a
certain group of new heroes - yeah
they're not as free as they think they
are
I do like Tommy's theory right and it's
such a nice easy way both to include
everything that happened in previous
films while also like giving us a little
bit of a fresh start we don't
we want to get back to those people
trying to crack their way out of the
illusion right and that's a cool way to
do the best that was great what I like
about it is it kind of answers that
question for people weren't satisfied
with Matrix Revolutions climax I felt it
was a bit too tied to monomyth hero the
Thousand Faces
Joseph Campbell Christ story because now
it just basically calls it out and says
no that was intentional because yeah
where it's just a machine following an
algorithmic script and there's a reason
behind that Tommy what would you call
your movie matrix read we call it matrix
refreshed that fresh fresh theory I I'm
gonna be real generous at the roadies
leaves the room the inflation rate gets
real
[Applause]
post-war Germany right now my pitch is
that
yeah Abdul Mateen and Jessica Heinrich
are born on the outside they're living
in that big cave system right and
they're not plugged in at all they never
have been but like the end of the last
Matrix movie people get the choice to
live in the matrix and be a pod or they
can be free and this is all not too far
from your allegory about modern times of
like people choose to go Seifer he wants
yeah and also he has a point like it's a
strong argument
so most what's happened is most people
are back in the matrix so out of like
ten people how many people want to be
eight yeah right like look at your phone
notifications how many hours do you
spend on your phone that's the procedure
happening my foot like my phone turned
on it was like you I woke up just to get
on my phone but so most of the people
are in back in the pods and so this new
cast of characters is determined to go
back in and help people because they
don't know what they're missing like
they're given the choice you know very
young to be like do you want to live
this very very hard life outside or do
you want to go back in it's it's Plato's
allegory right of the cave fire not the
cable or the fire but behind the fire
for sure you can either be burned alive
is that this cast so you're like okay we
have yeah Abdul Mateen we have just kind
of where are the original cast okay so
when they go back in when they take the
red pill or whatever it is that they
plug back into their matrix to free
everybody else they can choose they've
been updated they can choose who they
look like
your place your prayer right so a little
bit Jumanji right so you can go back in
and yeah Abdul Mateen goes back in and
he is Trinity he chooses to come back as
Trinity because she's already dead
she's been resurrected and what more
powerful of a figure to be like hey guys
like remember you your hero was one of
your heroes was dead and now she's back
to give you this very powerful message
Jessica hen what goes back in and is
Morpheus in the original Morpheus is the
one who convinces neo - yeah he's the
evangelical yeah yeah so he goes around
convincing people and every time they
but they don't succeed obviously at
first so they have to try again and they
can go back in as anyone they want and
that's when we get neo love it we get
all the other characters that yeah and
they can gender switch yeah that's what
lana wachowski wanted to do with
regional switch yeah
so now she gets to and it's and we get
to have a reboot but also explore cast
of new characters but we also get our
old favorites back I love that idea and
you know it that sounds like a really
really fun thing it sounds like what
ready player one try to do with those
themes I'm like you can be anyone yeah
and it's like yeah if you are aware of
that old mythology you would love to
play as a neo that would be character
you would love to play as Morpheus or
any of these characters and that gives
it's almost like what Jumanji has been
doing they're all kind of derivative of
the matrix which is also a derivative of
old stories ghost in the show other
avatar stories I love your theory so
much I'm going to give you two
and now those are equal to - Rosita - at
least for roadies and Marina tell us the
title of your matrix
away from tall bar de jump here okay and
I'm definitely not clearing the bar but
I will run face first in - okay okay
this movie is more grounded it's more
about human characters and like
physically it's more about like that
John wick [ __ ]
punched and kicked and it's less like
flying through the sky and setting off
like nuclear bombs of their body and
stuff like that and it's more like a
grounded reality and I think the way
they do that is this is centered on
Keanu Reeves is neo but right quick
recap a lot of The Matrix Revolutions
involved like in reloaded involves kind
of like Agent Smith and neo kind of like
weirdly rubbing off on each other right
it kills me kills Eden Smith at the end
of the first movie but then he comes
back kind of infected by some of me
right DNA and that lets him go rogue and
whatever and at the end they kind of
like assimilate into each other and the
neo blows both of them up to like kind
of in the war so like these two
characters are linked and so maybe when
we see Keanu Reeves now he's been
infected by agents and neo is the bad
guy is the Darth Vader he is the Anakin
of this movie and all these other
characters now have to take down yeah so
is he a new rebooted matrix or has he
been kind of reborn well
exist in both right and we saw in Matrix
sequels right that like the robots have
started to infect humans with the wood
beam right like so maybe yeah maybe he's
walking around in the caves of Zion like
looking like a John you know Depp or
John wick guy but like he's been
infected by like his experience okay you
know we could stop some of the same plot
elements you guys have brought up like
two different factions of humanity like
the kind of Pro matrix and then they
pro-freedom
kind of live outside the matrix and like
maybe maybe there's some more you know I
like the idea though that this is about
humans with maybe the programs and the
robots pulling some strings in the
background siding with one side of the
other but at at its core this is a human
story
yeah humans fighting you that's great
right because I think it's also a
takeaway of the sequel's is like when we
got like the Animatrix and all the
backstory it's like nobody was evil the
robots weren't necessarily evil in the
programs were evil they were at odds
often and they fought but hey you know
humans fight wars all the time is that
because one side's evil necessary
machines have no moral code it is we
humans for evil hey I love your theory
cuz it's like I I would love a like what
if we saw an evil neo just going through
that machine farm in the pods just like
John wick plugging each one two three
them that's like kind of fun too right
yeah yeah by the way there is still this
rumor that like John wick 4 and matrix 4
are gonna come out on the same day
[Music]
there is no wicks well Zach tell us and
I'll get back to you what would tell us
the title of your matrix 3 matrix retro
yes and Zach I love your theory so I am
going to give you I'm gonna give you one
I'm give you these - those were some
excellent matrix theory I would be
thrilled to see any of those and
hopefully elements of all three will
work it into in Lana Wachowski story and
let us know in the comments down below
what your ideal matrix were because to
me this is it's right up there with
multiverse of madness spider-man 3 Thor
11 Thunder this is gonna be the biggest
film of 2021 potentially so comment down
below with your ideal and before we talk
about how HBO can go into Watchmen
season 2 we want to give you a quick
message from a sponsor that helps us
make this show I'm gonna go over and
over to the blue dungeon to do it hey
Eric back in the blue dungeon here to
thank the sponsor of this episode bang
energy every can of bang is 16 ounces
that's right there's no wimpy 12 ounce
cans here it contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine it's sugar-free and a zero
calories yet it tastes great with over
20 flavors to choose from one of those
great flavors is bankster berry give it
a whirl yeah it's just it's solid great
berry taste I don't know if I like
something a bankster yet that's for you
to decide but it's not like this
overwhelming suffocating berry flavor
it's just like an accent of one and it
gives you plenty of energy like folks
there are some mornings I was up late
the night before writing a full movie
breakdown and I'm just like dragging
myself across the floor trying to get to
work
I can't bang energy helps pick me up so
I can starve last through some more work
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
when you use the code new rock stars 25
there you can get a variety tall pack
with a dozen of their flavors flavors
like pina colada cotton candy and yeah
thanks to Barry here berries that taste
so good bang is what you're gonna want
to do to him nose thanks again to bang
energy for sponsoring this video get 25%
off at bang - energy calm using the code
new rock stars 25 and follow the
inventor of bang on instagram at bang
energy that's the EOC had a different
shirt on
before we get to our next topic I want
to quickly check and remind everyone
that we have a new show on this channel
it is my favorite thing that we have
done and so long is called the big
question and it's a it's a to host show
usually it's Phillipa me sometimes we
have guests coming in Marina has been on
episode she's gonna be in the upcoming
episode maybe in a couple weeks and it's
just we tackle the biggest nerdiest
question and we give you too much
information too much research and we get
to some real dark conclusions like
Palpatine sexual history or the weird
ways baby Oh two ages and goes through
puberty and yeah Marina you were on that
we also drink like usually there's water
in our cups now but not for big question
I four big questions for big goes away
okay the new laws get written revoked
when he comes back so please check that
out and share it with if you like it
share it around because that's how we
need to get the word out about this so
we can keep doing more of it and more of
these kind of alternate formats cuz like
we're not gonna stop doing blue screen
stuff we're gonna be doing more and more
of that stuff but we want to like have
more opportunities to ask different
kinds of questions and big question it's
like our first big bold step in that
direction so share it around alright
let's talk about Watchmen guys the first
season of Watchmen HBO was it was a huge
critical and fan hit we all loved it
Damon Lindelof was a showrunner he said
that he wanted to tell a full story in
eight episodes and he did he did a great
job of that but he also said that he
might be done with it and he'll let
someone else tell a different story or
that he might just wait and see if he
gets more ideas for it in the future and
figure out where to take it from there
and so he has right now HBO has said
we're not gonna do a second season
without them it seems like they're
letting that season stand on its own and
then maybe sometime in the future
someone new will come along or Lindelof
will come off so I'm gonna let's take
that opportunity for us to pretend like
we are in front of HBO I'll be HBO for
this thought experiment and pitch to me
what new version of Watchmen you want to
do an additional season a completely new
take your Lindelof in this scenario and
and pitch to me what you want Watchmen
season 2 to focus on thanks for thanks
for every this pitch meeting with me
I'm very busy and I'm just watching a
lot of porn it's just porn it because
this channel light stories around there
like horny box office here I come hey
alright so I'm gonna bring in a new
director for the second season of
Watchmen and it's a director who crashed
at the box office but was overlooked for
a lot of awards who is Melina Masuka
Smoove directed Queen and slim where
would she take us she takes us back in
time to a Western okay it's a Western
season of Watchmen totally different
totally separate from season one and
Sitting Bull just decimates Custer's
right he kills them and all the other
army people with them and Sitting Bull
is just like a huge champion right and
we see how Sitting Bull becomes a legend
and a hero and a super hero right that's
real person but also super hero from
that point and he is the person who
assembles a new Western like magnificant
Magnificent Seven crew its Sitting Bull
it's Buffalo Bill it's Annie Oakley and
it's a lot of it's also Mexican American
characters because they were heavily
present in the Old West black characters
Chinese American characters because they
were present for the building of the
railroad they're all there yep see the
original American heroes were not
General Custer and not the American
government and not the white settlers
sorry y'all
it was uh the other people it was the
Native Americans it was the immigrants
it was the minorities and they had their
day they were on their way to the right
to rise to the top and then regular
America just squished him back down and
then we get our history books today but
she I think would focus on that and it
would be so cool and so badass and we
get a Western out of it oh yeah we need
more stories about like the Native
American origin indigenous people
because they
have been erased from our society and
like I want to hear more this because
our past name stores when he pitched
sounds a very interesting and it sounds
like de matically linked with the
trajectory of current watch man because
we saw this like back store with bass
Reeves who like a lot of people accused
the Lone Ranger of being ripped off from
bass Reeves which is a real figure in
American culture in American history so
it sounds like it's linked with that but
what's also cool about it is this whole
story of Custer like the seventh Cavalry
that's a got its name that was the group
that was with Custer and Custer's last
stand was like part of the so you have
like a literal link to the HBO show and
for that marina I'm gonna give you let's
see big look at this top score good so
thank you don't waste much of your time
okay but I would like to know what
happened in New York the monster did the
squid monster we Zak and I were talking
about it in like you know based on real
life you see how New York after 9/11
what happened with the city you know
with all the monuments and building the
Freedom Tower
even the like celebrity presence and
that's something Watchmen pulls so well
in the comics is taking real world
events in real world celebrity and and
putting them into the events that happen
in the comic book so like you know what
are the telephones that are happening in
New York City you know what what artists
are coming together to make a tribute
song about the square different pop
culture things you have so much fun with
and then I think you know the one
character we really didn't get much
information about is night owl oh yeah
he refuses to sign on after the Keene
act so we think he's in prison but like
I think we'll meet a guy who is there in
New York City when the attack the first
attack happens and we don't who follow
him in the current day and we won't
quite know for the first few episodes
what his catches but I think he's going
to either be and Roberts son or day rule
okay if you or somebody who has a
connection to night owl and will see
like
in the same way that so much happened in
the first season of Watchmen but it
really only happened in Tulsa ostensibly
there could be a ton of action going on
in New York City - you know there's
other things happening so I would like
to see the world of Watchmen established
in season one like that universe those
characters all exist but what's going on
northeast in New York City that's right
Tommy I like your idea and soon I'm
gonna reward you with a budget of three
roadies quite a stack okay thank you so
much for having me I I want to weave it
with a different historical event
different historical figure let's really
embrace the horror lift some of these
there's some really scary stuff what's a
scarier historical event than HH Holmes
and his murderer hotel yeah and viewer
if you're not familiar with HH Holmes go
look it up really scary real thing right
so what if like we go back in time kind
of like marinas idea and maybe this is
even in the same way that the Minutemen
were like the generation before the
original 80s Watchmen and we go back one
more generation look at some other group
yeah right the 32nd men or whatever
there's like another group that maybe
rises up to fight or to take down this
like menace of HH Holmes these people
disappearing right it's kind of dead
right you know like ground level because
I think another cool theme from the
graphic novel the first season
everything is that like vigilantism
doesn't work right right like all the
heroes in the Watchmen like are either
totally ineffective or like the good
they do is maybe bad right right you
could argue the most effective guy is
Ozymandias and it kills millions of
people copies what he wants but it's
like at what cost right and like dr.
Manhattan even the guy with true power
like doesn't necessarily use it for
great means so like I I would love to
explore like you know this maybe this
group of
like turn-of-the-century Little League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen watch mania
it's Kara
you and I both love the outsider yeah I
talk about it every Monday we're
watching the current HBO series I mean
and you sir is HBO executive Zach for
your HH home steampunk season because I
said steampunk and I'm just applying it
I'm going to give you a 1/4 oh geez give
them to Tommy / Susan B slam number one
inspired by the popularity of baby Yoda
artist Leonardo VT has created a baby
Jabba the Hutt what's the worst possible
character Star Wars or otherwise to make
a baby version of baby Jar Jar Binks
baby baby Hitler
for baby Hitler the most accurate of
what yeah baby Tommy gets the question
to the Robert Downey jr. story do little
ends and the spoiler with an extended
dragon rectal exam as a dragon fart a
pulls like bagpipes mythical creature
would have the worst smelling farts I
would say it's got to be the minute are
you something
the Matar has a fairly consistent diet
eating a lot of hedge maze transforms
his body to be different animals and
different beef so he's eating a lot of
different diets it's just a combination
in his stomach of like a hawk that eats
Road Edison birds and then like a sea
creature that eats brine and shrimp and
then a man that eats big beefy steaks I
think that's got to be the grossest
[ __ ] I've ever it is now anyone's
game all right
yeah a Karate Kid musical is in the
works
you asked me a song from Karate Kid to
the musical and sing it if you can my
song is called sometimes you stand on a
pole and it goes like this
sometimes you stand on a pole and
sometimes you get the best roll
sometimes you have to do karate oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
my song is called it's from the
perspective of Johnny's mother I bought
my teenage son skeleton costume for
Halloween I thought about taking my life
today as I looked upon my son you put on
his grown-up skeleton costume I hate
myself a little kid don't know what I
just did Johnny I'm not your real mom
your real mom was a hooker philosophy
wax on wax off wax needs to go on move
your right hand you move your left you
have to move your right hand right there
this is very hard for me but I think the
winner is going to be Tommy everyone has
to send Phillip a get-well message it's
been a pleasure I'll probably never be
allowed to do it thanks to our guest
marina masters anything you got and I'll
be on big question soon oh that's right
Tommy back told okay follow me at Tommy
Bechtold and follow me in real life
gene Aziz pizza on tables tonight and of
course off-screen producers that hello
don't follow me anywhere
I'll be off-screen don't forget to
subscribe to the new rock stars rogue
theory podcast feed and can stay tuned
to the YouTube channel for this and lots
of other shows including big question
also this stuff we talked about you can
follow a new rock circle sweater at
narakasura follow me at da boss and
Philip my friend got a pull through this
because we don't have enough props on
this set to award so get back here in
return and restore order Philip you know
I've never met anybody before that's
been an ace celery accident but you know
what if anybody can pull through and get
those little green strings out of their
teeth it's you buddy
you're strong pass for Philip we begged
you not to ride that horse without a
saddle but now your balls have been
pulverized and we wish you a speedy
recovery God knows I need you back here
sooner than later Philip when you opened
that canister of protein powder and you
and you inhaled with that reckless
abandon you filled your lungs by
accident with chocolate and you were
have been in the hospital for months but
I'm wishing you well I'm wishing you hot
tea recovery tea with honey and may that
protein powder make its way out of your
lungs out of your mouth and back into
this chair where it belongs
see when I filled my lungs with
chocolate I turn into this
[Applause]
[Music]